(guitar strumming)
- [Jack, Ahmed,
Ryan] Dead Kevin.
- Jack?
Ryan?
Sweet, home alone!
(humming & scatting)
The grape juggler is (mumbles).
- Ryan?
Ahmed?
(guitar)
Thank you Cleveland,
this has been a dream!
- Dun dun dun dun, dunna, dunna.
Ladies and gentleman,
Ryan gets the ball.
He comes around the corner,
he breaks out of a tackle,
he's in the open field, he
spins out of another tackle,
and he's in for the touch down!
Whooo!
The crowd goes wild!
(imitates screaming fans)
Oh they love him!
Don't they just love him?!?!
Oh Ryan, you won the
game, how do you feel man?
Oh, I tell you what, it's a
team game, but I feel good.
God, I look good.
That was such a game.
God, I feel so good.
(imitates screaming fans)
Geez.
Oh my god.
Dun, dun, dun,
dun, dunna, dunna.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
(imitates screaming fans)
I'm going to Disney World.
(screaming and mumbling)
- Welp, I'm gonna go to bed.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- Alright.
(guitar strums)
- Hey everyone does weird
stuff when they're home alone.
Why don't you tell us
about your funniest
home alone stories in
our comment section.
And like our videos
and subscribe to our
YouTube channel
Dead Kevin Sketch.
You ready?
- Yeah let's do it.
(distorted whirring)